so David first thing I have to ask is um
the mustache in the estate was that
homegrown or was that a prosthetic
that was real that was the first time
I've ever quite
quite grown it out uh uh separate from
beer to in fact like the day
I got to set the day before I was
supposed to start working and I went
through wardrobe which was a revelation
and and really like a cue to the
character for me uh Dana Embry was the
Wardrobe who was she was amazing and
then I went to the makeup trailer and I
called Dean who was Dean Craig who was
working on set
because they were already shooting
and it says you got to come in here
because we got to figure out this facial
hair I had a full bearded mustache and I
knew I wanted to trim it somehow and I
was like I don't know it's either going
to be just a mustache or mustache and a
little goatee like but we got to make an
executive decision here come on down we
went down there and we were like
seriously talking about like what's
funnier facial hair
with the mustache you know and the
response I've got of the mustache I can
only tell me that we made the right
choice
what has the response been how how did
your family react to it
my son said nice stash
um but uh he's he's growing one himself
I think he's been inspired by his old
man
but you know the young kids they grow an
ironic mustache my mustache was very
sincere yes
um and you mentioned that that going to
wardrobe was kind of a a revelation for
you can you talk about in what way
well I had spoken to Dana
um beforehand and when she said how do
you see this guy and I said I see him in
like you know three thousand dollar
Gucci track suits you know and she said
I I love it I just I don't have that
money you know and I was like okay let's
find a couple tracksuits that might
might give us their you know for free
and we did we found this this weird
tracksuit that has like it has like
women as it's Insignia I don't know if
you can read it in the movie but there's
like yeah they're like the the mudflap
girls exactly exactly so that took the
place of like uh a more expensive brand
and then she just pulled some stuff and
I was like uh yeah and then there was
like five dollar pair of pants those
light purple ones stuff like that and I
I just said these are these are great
you know and it was really
I've never been like an actor that's
like gotten into the Wardrobe of the
character before it's usually like
I I concern myself of other things but I
maybe it's going to change the way I
work because I was like oh as soon as I
got these these clothes I was like oh I
get this guy now like it all kind of
like fell in the place which was really
lucky because it was the day before we
were shooting so
um so tell me a little bit about what
Drew you to the role
well I mean it reminded me a little bit
of Californication and that this was a
role where
you know you had a truth teller in a way
even though his truth is ridiculous and
and vile
um and
I really love Unapologetic characters
they're hard to find you can find them
in comedy sometimes but you know in life
in a drama you can't really
you don't apologize I Unapologetic
character is hard to find him from maybe
like There Will Be Blood or movies like
that you know the few and far between
because they're horrific if they're not
treated you know comedically
um but if I can find one I kind of try
to embrace that and I I think I
understand what it means to be funny in
that thing
um I think it's probably why I responded
to Californication back in the day as
like okay this is a guy that says what's
on his mind and doesn't care about the
consequences and Richard is different in
that he says what's on his mind because
he doesn't even understand
so was it difficult for you to play kind
of a creepy lecherous character or was
it was it fun getting to kind of step
away from step into someone who I assume
that you are not like as a human being
thank you thank you for the Assumption I
think that that
um the the answer to that would be sure
but like
um you know the trick for me as an actor
is and and I and it's been cliche and
it's become a bit of a cliche now is
that
um you know that guy doesn't think of
himself as lecherous or anything that
guy just thinks of himself as that guy
you know and he's got his wants and
desires and the rest of the world be
damned he's just kind of a he's just
kind of a fun narcissist and when you
get to play a narcissist in a comedy
you don't deal with the wreckage that a
real narcissist causes in life you just
get to see somebody who just loves
themselves and it's kind of contagious
yeah and I know a few benign narcissists
in my life and you just kick yourself
because you're like God this guy's fun
to hang around with you know because
they just love they love everything they
do there's no self-doubt there's no
nothing
and I think sometimes we like to watch
that because it's so rare for most of us
to not have that other voice in your
head saying
you sure about this yeah
I think I identified a little too much
with Richard which is probably not a
good thing for me no that's what comedy
is for you know it's like it turns
things upside down yeah
um were there any bits that were too
raucous or too dirty that were left on
The Cutting Room floor
I don't know I mean once you get past
the scene where you know we're dealing
with the guy with his penis out
um I think I don't know what I don't
know what goes on The Cutting Room floor
if that makes it in the movie you know
so I'm right
I I think one of the funniest moments
that I had on set was
being with Dean Craig when they were
bringing him various penises and which
one you know it wasn't like let's choose
the best penis it was like which is the
funniest penis and then we would have a
discussion about what makes the penis
funny or not and it was just the most
ridiculous conversation you could ever
have but very serious
what does make a penis funny
yeah I would I'm not going to go into
details because uh
you know I don't want to alienate any of
the penises out there if you know what
I'm saying
[Music]
um so you kind of reunited with Tony
Collette and Kathleen Turner on this
movie you've worked with both of them
before what was that like was it kind of
like a homecoming or did they not even
remember you like oh yeah yeah they
didn't remember me
um
Kathleen was fun to work with again uh
you know we do we kind of
tread the same ground on Californication
where you know kind of a sex farce
comedy kind of stuff
um and I knew she was totally game you
know to do this kind of stuff and that
was great and Tony and I did Connie and
Carla but we didn't really do much
together
um I I did get to you know
we did become friendly back then and you
know we did work a little bit but you
know I'm a big fan of Tony's as an
actress so
uh it was fun to work with a lot of good
actors who all approach comedy a little
differently and to be able to like for
instance like Kayla Monterosa to me is
some kind of a
weirdo genius you know and that you know
and I'd seen her on Curb Your Enthusiasm
but really has
targeted her as like oh that that person
has really interesting angles you know
that she comes from and I'd watch her in
this movie you know as somebody in the
scene with her and she it was it's just
very interesting to watch somebody
you know and to I really I really kind
of appreciate what she's doing as well
and just Switching gears a little bit
can you tell me a little bit about uh
Kepler your graphic novel
yeah
um what how is writing a graphic novel
different from writing a regular novel
it's a lot less writing
there's a lot more pictures
um yeah I mean I I that's I'm joking
when I say that but that's really
that was my experience because I had
written
I'd written Kepler as kind of a
versus kind of a teleplay like I I saw
it as a TV series
and then um started developing it
towards being a graphic novel and I soon
realized how very little you can put in
a graphic that's very similar to writing
screenplay actually where where the
images are telling your story and not
not the writing so having you know
found my love of writing again in the
last six or seven years and
I kind of I kind of had to put that
aside because
um
it was just like well what's it was it
was it's this is very uh condensed and
very
um it's almost it's almost like writing
poetry it has to be that condensed and
has to do so much so what I loved about
writing novels as opposed to trying to
write screenplays is that I could kind
of relax and just expand and
and just write and and this was more of
a
uh more of a screenplay feeling to to
it's very much like experience I mean
it's like storyboards it's like a
screenplay with storyboards cool well
they're telling me I have to get out so
um thank you very much
yeah they were
um uh thank you very much and I loved
the movie and uh thank you